all right Playboy
Playboy uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally well I grew up in
San Diego Valley you know Belinda it's
an unincorporated City in uh La Puente
suburb of L.A yes
tell me about your family mom and dad
um my mom was adopted and uh my dad was
born in Watts California
and my mom was raised in South Central
in uh mid in high school
and uh been married
started having kids and uh
that's when the Watts Riots broke out
back then before I was born
and which uh
LED them to move out of Watch
to San Diego Valley
I guess uh
they thought it'd be a better life but
the game started up right there and
you know my brothers were all from my
neighborhood
and which
we got raised into the neighborhood
and you know my house was a shooting
gallery
my brother was a pierogi I was friends
of Parolees
all heroin addicts tattooed gang members
and uh
I just thought it was a get a kick out
of watching uh you know a 19 year old
not out on heroin you know
you know they give me little Cottons and
heroin
made me sick sicker than a dog I mean um
didn't like it but
I still wanted to fit in wanted to be
anything that they were part of
so I kept on asking for it
would get school
and by the time I turned out 12 years
old
I thought it was you know it was the
right time for me to be jumped into my
neighborhood
and uh
they had me going out on missions um
you know assaulting other gang members
stealing
and uh
the cops came and hit the house where
one of my brothers and I found a bunch
of drug paraphernalia guns
in the house and uh I was only juvenile
so they uh took me and put me in Foster
facility care
and uh
I ran away from the
the McLaren Hall
and um
they put a Nobel warrant out for me I
ended up in Judy
and sent to another boy's home
ran away from that one and uh
again became a revolving door from
juvenile hall boys homes
um
I would go home
you know and try to hide from the law
and uh my mom and dad were too busy
fighting with each other he was a little
abusive
to my mom and to us
he was a good provider though
but um he just uh I mean he was really
angry man
and uh
so by the time I turned 15 already me
and one of my homeboys had hit every
Circle K you could imagine
all throughout San Diego Valley
you know all Southern California liquor
stores were robbing them gunpoint and uh
I got arrested
and they I took a deal where they
convicted me of three armed robberies
I got six years in California Youth
Authority
ended up in Norwalk srcc
and uh
and then when I turned 18.
[ __ ] so um I mean Jimmy G star of huge
training school in uh in Chino
ygs and um
and there's nothing but gang banging
violence
learned how to fight they called it
Gladiator School
you know how to fight you learn how to
um
learn how to survive you know
and uh
I got out when I was 19.
stood out for like a month
went back till I was 21.
um
discharged in Hawaii number
got almost 21 same month I picked up a
prison number
ended up in a in Tehachapi and reception
and then from there um
ended up in uh in chuckawalla Valley
State Prison
and uh
became a soldier for the Mexican Mafia
and
you know
learn how to
tax others
other gang members for drugs
collect rent
you know I've seen a lot of violence
you feel like you had any choice
as a kid when you were a young teen no I
I didn't feel there's a choice at all I
mean
I even had a over
gang members
tell me uh
and you ain't got a prison number yet
man what's up man you mean
and to to bring me to them it was uh
if you didn't catch a prison number yet
if something's wrong with you you know
so uh
yeah I I didn't have a choice you know
that was it you know
um
become a gang member parole
and uh and throughout all my 20s 30s I'm
45 now but uh yeah I in and out of
prison you're not a prison
I've been shot four times
stabbed
I have assaulted other people in the
same manner
yeah you're just a
a rough life you know how much prison
time have you done overall
um all together I got about a good
good 25 years in the system
what was what were some of the offenses
before
um possession of a firearm
gang member with the firearm
um taking a vehicle without owner's
consent
burglaries
assaults of getting ripping
attempted murder
and that's not including all the the
parole violations
and uh as I got a little older I you
know became a
came and Associated you know mixing
Mafia
and after that you know you know there
is no choice you know
you're you're eating that you you know
you're married to that you know it comes
first
before your mom before your dad before
your kids your wife
and you have no choice you know that's
it
do you believe in karma
oh yeah yeah believe in karma my karma
hits me really fast
really fast it's gonna hit me
you know uh when something goes right
um I know right around the corner
something's going to go wrong you know
uh yeah Karma's real it's real easy
especially in my life
in drugs are still a part of your life
yes have it been throughout
um yeah I did all my whole life it's
been a part of my life
um
never really been sober
even in the system
there's more drugs in there than there
was on the streets
and especially uh being part of like a
prison gang
um you know you get you collect a third
of all drugs from every inmate that hits
them you know that gets on
so yeah I've been strung out in in the
system in prison I've been strung out on
heroin
good emotions do you go through now
oh wow I got a lot of PTSD
a lot of PTSD
um
I uh I'm walking to the stores and
um all eyes on me here
we put Morata a crowd of
people right away I started thinking
that I'm going to get assaulted
or or you know I mean sometimes I
take off on somebody thinking that
they're gonna hit me first so I better
hate them strike version of them you
know
yeah so PTSD is a really big part of my
life you know
what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear is um
becoming an old man in prison
uh being stuck there
being told to do
I have children you know I have eight
kids
they're all adults you know
my biggest fear is uh
my son's
um
leading in the same footsteps that I do
I mean it was mine
I uh I have a son that recently was
released from prison he did nine years
in prison
um my other son was murdered
a year and a half ago
sir and Stockton he uh
his mother has a daughter from a
previous marriage
and she was she's imprisoned during 18
years so
she moved from Victorville to Stockton
to be closer to her daughter so she can
visit her more often and they ended up
in a Northern neighborhood
and
my son now
he's always trying to be like me he was
19 years old he's always trying to be
like me and I got a tattoo of a Playboy
bunny on the side of my face
and he got the same tattoo
you know I'm just trying to be like like
me well not knowing that
that Northern
game
the Playboy Bunny to them is a symbol of
a of a prison Dropout gang
called Northern Riders
it represents that
and
they were thinking that he was that
and
he was a
in a car with his friends on a weekend
drinking
and they pulled up behind the car and
they shot at the vehicle six times with
the 40 caliber
hang on and one of the bullets struck my
my son in the back of the head
and um
the driver of the vehicle
uh
drove with my sons in the car still
straight to
his mom's house to my baby's mom's house
you know
jumped off the car and ran in there and
told him told her hey uh
Stevie got shot get him out of my car
um I don't want no problem with the cops
you know get him out of my car he got
shot
she said that she went outside and
opened the car door to open the
passenger door and he was slumped over
with his head like on the dashboard and
she said when she pulled him back
his whole face was gone you know the
bullet uh tore his whole face off we
entered the back of his head and came
out the front of his face
and uh
you know I was clean for a while off of
drugs you know I was doing all right
and um
when I got the news my brother my
brother called me I was in a motel room
with uh with one of my girlfriends and
he told me it didn't matter you know I
broke down and I cried and I you know
just it it
and you know he just sent me to a dark
place and I started using heroin again
and uh
yeah I mean they just tore me apart man
you know I I blame myself
uh
you know I I should have been there
you know
I should have been a better father to
him you know
and yeah
you know I don't know
you know God works in mysterious ways I
know that and I just don't understand
why I've done way more than
my kids have done I've done more dirt
and I'm still here on this Earth and
for them to get killed before my son get
killed and then
me to survive 45 years is just I don't
know it trips me out like
you know I don't know what God has
planned for me or what not but why am I
still here you know
um
I would have been a heartbeat I would
have took his place you know
yeah that haunts me
yeah and yeah so that's a
one of my biggest fears he has my kids
you know
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently oh wow
I've already done well I would have done
a lot of things different I would have
uh
student school when I went to college I
would uh
you know I always since a kid I wanted
to be a I always wanted to be a law
enforcement you know that was one of my
dreams as a young kid
um
I would have probably pursued a career
in that probably went to the military
I like structure you know
uh
I like self-discipline
well yeah I had to do all over again I
would have been a way better man you
know
and I would ever raise my kids
you know the right way you know
I lost my parents when I was in prison
they passed away
I'm kind of like now I'm on the streets
I'm hoping this uh
I don't got really much family anymore
you know my brothers and sisters have
all passed away
and uh it's just me out here you know
and I
I
I
plan
on doing good and trying to get my stuff
get my my life together you know
I laid off the alcohol I got a drug
problem I'm trying to try to harness you
and I'm trying to get some housing and
uh
when I make it
I I plan on helping other
kids maybe counseling other gang members
and uh
you know just trying to um
try to save some kids from
you know taking the same steps with my
kids ending up like my son Stephen you
know
and uh because uh no partnership goes
with that I mean the I can't explain the
the feeling it is to lose you don't need
to lose your child you know especially
to uh to some violence and such you know
what do you think of the whole gang
subculture
seems very popular especially here in
Southern California and California as a
whole
you know uh
yeah I'll be honest I'll be honest with
you if you disgusts me it does
when I finally got to you know the top
of the hill where I wanted to be the
rank that I wanted to have when I
finally got there and looked around and
it wasn't what I thought it would
just was no loyalty there was no no love
there was no family there was no
it was a bunch of snakes you mean
uh just doing whatever it took hurting
each other to
step on stepping on each other to get to
the top you know
a lot of snakes cut throats
um there's no
there's no honor no royalty you know
and uh yeah what I think about it I
don't think much about it I you disgust
me you know
matter of fact you know like uh when
people ask me like hey you know
what are these statues mean or or they
start talking about gangs and stuff um I
try to change the subject you know
because
when someone glorifies it apparently
it angers me you know
because it's uh it's a big lie you know
to be like
and when I see other youngsters
hard-headed youngsters and I know I
can't get across to them because I know
I was in that
I was in that that you know same
position before uh it hurts you know
and sometimes I ask God like you know
please give me give me some weights and
teach me how to get through to some kids
you know so they don't make the same
mistakes that I have you know
wow yeah
my son dying and all that and he took a
lot of fight out of me it took a lot of
took a lot out of me and uh
yeah you know what
yeah I got no more fighting me like that
you know
uh
yeah I'd like I'd like to help people
I'd like to help other kids you know
Anthony what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
foreign lesson I've learned in my life
was Cherish your family
cherisher Banned Me With Your Parents uh
listen I mean
we're not promised tomorrow you know
anything could happen and
you know space
you know you could recover a lot of
things but
time you can't recover you know
when someone's gone it's gone you know
um
yeah that's one of the biggest listeners
in the life to cherish your people
cherish your loved ones
and I love one another you know
you know because
that's what uh without
helping people without helping each
other we won't ever make it you know
yeah that's true that's I'd like to see
that's the biggest lesson I've heard you
know
all right Anthony thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you the best of
luck all right thank you thank you